[Música]
hora de hablar de economía aquí en
directo a América y para eso nos
acompaña Jorge Hurtado Jorge buenas
noches bienvenido Buenas noches María
Clara Bueno ayer estábamos hablando de
la decisión del Banco Central de Estados
Unidos de mantener la tasa de interés
hoy el banco europeo toma otra decisión
y los aumenta Así es esto como parte de
su lucha contra la inflación de hecho la
doctrina económica manda que cuando la
inflación comienza a subir se debe
aumentar el costo del dinero para frenar
el aumento de los precios que es a
propósito es uno de los mayores
problemas económicos que afecta a los 20
países de la eurozona los detalles si
los tiene nuestro compañero Juan Armando
rojas
los créditos más caros en dos décadas el
Banco Central europeo elevó a 3,5% su
tasa de interés intentando atajar el
alto costo de vida en consecuencia los
bancos europeos pagarán más por sus
depósitos en la banca central lo cual se
trasladará a un mayor costo de los
créditos a familias y empresas con la
medida se busca frenar las salsas que
afectan los bolsillos de los
consumidores
[Música]
los riesgos del alza para la inflación
incluyen posibles presiones alcistas
renovadas sobre el coste de la energía y
los alimentos también relacionadas con
la guerra de Rusia contra Ucrania Un
aumento en las expectativas de inflación
por encima de nuestra meta o aumento
superiores en salarios o los márgenes de
beneficio también podrían impulsar la
inflación al alza en Europa los
intereses no habían estado tan altos
desde 2001 y aunque la inflación se dé
sigue siendo muy alta por ahora no se
ven las condiciones para congelar ni
bajar los intereses
pero en lo que respecta al Banco Central
europeo dije lo que dije hemos subido
las tasas de interés a menos que haya un
cambio continuaremos subiendo las en
nuestra próxima reunión Así que no
estamos pensando en hacer una pausa
en un hecho inusual el aumento de
intereses se da Después de que la
reserva Federal en Estados Unidos
decidiera no ajustar sus tipos de
interés a futuro El Banco Central
europeo está resuelto a subir más las
tasas hasta controlar la carestía
Jorge pasemos Ahora sí a Estados Unidos
porque va en aumento el número de
ciudadanos que está pidiendo ayuda por
desempleo Bueno Este es un efecto a
propósito de que la subida de los tipos
de interés en ese país comienzan a
mostrar sus frutos el departamento de
trabajo dijo que el número de
solicitudes de subsidio de desempleo en
Estados Unidos Fue de 262.000 en la
semana que terminó el 10 de junio de
hecho las cifras de solicitudes de Las
dos últimas semanas son las más altas
desde octubre del 2021 como recordarán
los empleadores estadounidenses vienen
agregando puestos o vacantes de forma
acelerada luego de la pandemia que borró
20 millones de empleos Esto hace que los
estadounidenses tengan de alguna forma
una buena seguridad laboral a pesar de
la agresiva campaña de la reserva
Federal de Estados Unidos para enfriar
la economía y también el mercado laboral
en ese país la Fed quiere menos empleos
para domar la inflación pero el mercado
laboral parece resistir a estas subidas
de los tipos de interés los empresarios
estadounidenses crearon
nueve mil puestos de trabajo en el mes
pasado mientras la tasa de desempleo
subió al 3,7 ahora
una sí Bueno pues a partir del 27 de
junio lo va a poder hacer porque ese día
será la primera misión espacial con un
vuelo comercial vamos a ir reservando
los cupos para nuestro siguiente vuelo
así lo anunció Virgin galactic holdings
que es la empresa de turismo espacial de
Richard branson el vuelo llamado
galactic01 llevará a bordo a los
investigadores de la fuerza aérea
italiana y del consejo nacional de
investigación de Italia hablamos del
inicio de los vuelos comerciales de
Virgin galactic luego de numerosos
retrasos y también abre el camino para
que más personas puedan hacer turismo en
el espacio una vez completada la misión
Virgin galactic tiene previsto realizar
un segundo vuelo comercial a principios
de agosto de este año Aunque la idea
según dijeron María Clara es hacer
misiones mensuales en el futuro bueno
Esperemos entonces Todavía no desde el
27 de junio pero ya llegará su momento
Jorge ahora cuéntenos cómo van las
acciones de la cadena de restaurantes
estadounidense cava entraron a la bolsa
de Nueva York y se duplicaron bueno la
empresa superó el objetivo de su oferta
pública inicial al recaudar 318 millones
de dólares lo que supuso una de las
mayores ganancias del primer día en dos
años Ahora la capitalización bursátil de
esta empresa se ubica en 2.200 millones
de dólares la oferta pública inicial de
este restaurante mediterráneo es uno de
los pocos brillos en los mercados
bursátiles Durante un año bastante
sombrío para las salidas en bolsa en
Estados Unidos ahora los inversores
esperan que este éxito anime a otras
empresas a seguirla en el mercado y
contribuya también a poner fin a esta
mala racha de la captación de capital y
qué sorpresa nos tiene para hoy con la
cifra del día uno de estos segmentos
favoritos Bueno hoy la cifra es
12.600 dólares eso cuesta la preventa de
las entradas al posible debut de Leo
Messi en el Inter de Miami aunque no
está confirmada la fecha los aficionados
esperan que el Debut sea el 21 de Julio
cuando el inter va a jugar contra el
Cruz Azul de México para ese partido la
entrada más barata cuesta 950 dólares
mientras que para el partido del 4 de
julio se pueden comprar en 29 Dólares y
también había otras fechas de alrededor
de 100 dólares por lo que la llegada de
Messi sin duda alguna incrementó los
precios Jorge Gracias por todas las
noticias económicas nos vemos en la
próxima nos vemos en la próxima y
nosotros continuamos con el debate